i want to um start this next segment
with a reminder or or sort of a notice i
guess and i don't know that people are
necessarily thinking in these terms
the election is about to get going
voting starts in six weeks the first
absentee ballots are going to be going
out in north carolina on september 4th
in pennsylvania they go out on september
14th in michigan they go out on
september 19th and this is
incredibly important for a few reasons
number one
trump doesn't really have three and a
half months to to fix
something or to have some big win to get
voters back
for many voters he has six weeks and
when you look at
those three states that will most soon
be voting
biden is up ahead is up by two in north
carolina
up by seven in pennsylvania and up by
seven in michigan those are averages of
recent pollings according to real clear
politics
this means that the election is
essentially now
trump has six weeks to turn around the
polls
in those states because as people start
voting in september and october
that leaves fewer people whose minds can
be changed
in the second half of october and in the
last days before the election so
the closing arguments of the campaign as
it were need to start
happening very very soon in 2016 47
million people voted before election day
either with in-person early voting or
vote by male absentee
the assumption this year because of
coronavirus is that
there will be dramatically more than 47
million people voting
either early or by mail especially by
mail i
sent in my absentee ballot request form
yesterday
so this means a few different things
number one
the vigilance about voter suppression
has to be escalated dramatically now
i've made an effort since last election
not to do the thing where i start
talking about voter suppression
october 5th right of the year of the
election we've been talking about voter
suppression
for years at this point we've been
covering the voter purges we've been
covering the opposition to vote by mail
we've been talking about voting machines
and all of it
so it should already be up but we need
to even talk more about that and i'm
going to talk more about that on friday
we would expect that the president will
become
even more erratic sooner than later but
really we now need to realize what it is
that we're doing here you know people
talk about
the most important election of my life
i believe this is the most important
election i will be voting in
so you know we talked a little bit about
this on the bonus show before
think about the 2012 election barack
obama had been president for four years
significant recovery uh from the great
recession
of 2008 um economic expectations were
positive and you can find clips of me
saying
in october of 20 2012 i'm voting for
obama over mitt romney
but the reality is that if romney wins
we're probably going to have a good
economy for the for the next four years
all indicators were that the traditional
economic signals were pretty solid
that the economic policy of mitt romney
would certainly
tweak the trajectory a little bit but
romney had a different tax policy idea
romney had a different health policy
idea but generally speaking
whoever won in 2012 was going to preside
over four
relatively good years in the economy by
all the standard
measures this is a very different
situation than what we have today
and so it wasn't that the 2012 election
wasn't important but even at the time
not just in retrospect i remember having
the recognition and it's on record in
video clips you can go and fact check me
that this was not the most important
election i was participating in
we now are in a situation where we will
either have four years of damage done by
a reactionary ignorant buffoon
or we are going to have eight years of
an even
more compromised more unhinged trump
in the latter four of those eight years
we
are sort of on the precipice of either
diving even deeper into the deep end of
ignorance and narcissism
or we can start to get the house in
order
we can start to regain respect from our
traditional allies
we can start to get away from being the
laughing stock that we have become
we can resume dealing with the climate
crisis we've gone the opposite direction
on climate
uh unfortunately joe biden has adopted
elements from the green new deal and
from bernie sanders climate platform so
is it perfect no but we we you know you
know this analogy or this this example
of
if a boat leaves new york uh across the
atlantic ocean
what after 10 miles is only a difference
of a few hundred yards in terms of the
angle
can end up with you in europe or africa
uh as you cross the atlantic ocean so
that's the importance of starting to
right the ship
today we hopefully would be
seeing an increase rather than a
decrease in the number of people with
health insurance if joe biden were to
win
in november we could stop worrying that
if a supreme court justice were to get
sick or die or retire
it would plague us with decades more of
the conservative nonsense that we've
been seeing
so these are not trivial matters and i
know it
feels like a way off november it's more
than three months for some voters it
starts in six weeks
for many voters the decision about who
they're going to vote for is going to be
made in the next four to five weeks and
they will
vote in six weeks so time is flying
right now for a lot of us
the days look quite similar uh those of
us who are still socially distancing
four months in quarantine
each day felt long but the four months
have just flown by
six weeks are going to fly by the next
three months are going to fly by and if
i don't
um feel that i've done everything i can
to stop this insanity i would not be
able to live with myself
so it is now election time we've got the
conventions coming up in whatever
form they take place uh we have
potentially debates coming up
and voting starts in six weeks the
opportunity
will be there for october surprises and
then that's it i mean this thing is
almost over
are we going to have four more years of
utter depravity or can we remove this
lunacy from the oval office and start to
it's just the start it's just
turning the ship can we start to
reintroduce sanity to
our federal leadership and of course one
of the biggest issues to consider
is coronavirus and that's what i want to
talk about a little bit next